[Music]
okay so as we heard a talk from bamboo
healthcare yesterday their team has this
baby incubator like a set up which helps
babies who are either bronc prematurely
or who have been in the ICU for a day or
more when they are brought back home how
can we also give them a level of care
especially in rural areas so they've
developed a system which can have a
smartphone tracking the baby and they
also ask questions to be regularly
through nurses so we thought of how we
can use AI for such a system and this is
I'm speaking on behalf of our team of
course people from bamboo health care
presented from MSR India we have Jackie
a u.s. CEO Brian was a team member and
from IIT Delhi on cap and Galal
are in the team so our societal problem
is to prevent neonatal deaths and not
all babies can be kept in ICUs so you
have to think of what we can do when
they are at home just when they are
discharged and these are high-risk ways
low birth weight premature and the
current climate is that there are kind
of two solutions available there either
Asha workers who are supposed to make
home visits but it's hard for them to
keep track and they cannot visit as
often and the second solution is what
bamboo has proposed which is more like a
sensor based system and what we would
like to do is to see how they can deploy
this proposal and the system to many
more patients and they tell us they
actually the problem they have is that
it's not the government if they actually
have approval to deploy this to many
more children but the problem is they
don't have the resources because there's
is a very resource instant intensive
model so they have doctors who look at
these videos and they also have nurses
who call twice every day each of these
parents of babies right so we thought
one way AI or machine learning could
help is in simply predicting risk of
different babies as we get data from
them right and I'll talk about the exact
kinds of data we have and the second
problem we can also think of is that it
might help in two ways one is it can
reduce the manual effort so for example
if a nurse has
10 or 20 babies to keep track of every
day the nurse may prioritize who to call
and who to ask more questions and spend
more time with as a triage and the
second is it can also help bampo
healthcare scale-up their system to more
people and also look at which signals
are really important so maybe it is that
the video some parts of the video not
important or maybe some questions are
not important so based on this analysis
they would be able to fine-tune their
system for a low cost and so the
concrete problem we have identified is
that we would like to look at all the
signals that we get currently from bampo
system and just model for now as a
simple classification problem is the
baby at its current state healthy or is
they are they showing any signs of
abnormality or extremely they need some
medical attention right now so these are
the three categories bampo healthcare
already has labeled in their data so in
our case we have already some data
available which their team is happy to
share after this workshop the data
consists of hundred patients on which
they have the system deployed they found
that out of them four were readmitted so
they were really extreme cases and
twenty required follow-up and because
they were doing at a very manually
intensive way they were able to track
these patients and do the follow-up so
what we are thinking off is if we have
the data which is demographic and
history medical history of the baby we
have the vital signs data for some
patients not all because they have these
sensors we have videos for per day which
means like four times the camera
activates and records the video and then
we have two phone calls from nurses
which is also happens twice per day
right so even though it might look that
we only have 100 patients if you look at
the actual sample size there's four
videos per day for each maybe they have
two weeks so it's about 70 data points
approximately per baby so proposed
solution will go in two parts one is
that we're gonna do an exploratory
analysis first just to see which kinds
of signals are more predictive or
correlated with bad outcomes either an
abnormality or a needs attention and the
second task would be based on these
insights you want to build a classifier
to predict whether a baby is healthy or
not and the idea is that if and you want
to be conservative so you only want to
say a baby is healthy when it's on the
far end of really healthy if we find any
sign of abnormality we actually want to
raise it and then have a nurse or a
doctor take it from there and finally of
course it also can have been poo later
on to fine-tune their product to only
call to only collect a certain set of
data and not all and these are some
examples of images that they have
collected and we would like to
essentially let's say if this baby is
healthier then this baby then we want to
check that and
be able to use video alright so the
estimated impact this is just a
calculation that we did among the team
members we have found that for babies
out of the hundred that are on trial
required readmission and so what it
means is that as we get more and more
babies in these systems the nurses could
prioritize and therefore get more people
having a chance to be treated and
readmitted to hospitals and it will also
help us to think of how we can also
enable the Asha workers were not a part
of this system but maybe that learnings
that we have of either phone calls or
some kinds of sensors could also be used
when are sure workers do their visits
ethical concerns I think there are sort
of two ethical concerns that we
discussed so the first is patients might
get if our detector is raising a lot of
alarms for no reason parents might get
worried and get anxious for no reason
the other more serious one is that if
our detector makes mistakes parents
might feel nothing everything is fine
whereas their baby might be having a
medical problem
our current solution but this is to be
as conservative as possible to not raise
so always it's better to raise false
alarms than not in our case at least we
think but this is something we have to
talk to doctors and
put him to figure this trade off the
other two are I think a common concern
with using data so we would want to
protect patient information so I think
we'll try to see if we can anonymize all
the data and especially the videos and
also have patient consent which bamboo I
think already has for doing research of
this data now one concern although it's
not an ethical concern I think it's more
of a data concern is that not all of the
parents comply so we won't have data for
all of these babies on all times but I
think that's also an interesting an
interesting technical challenge to look
at so account with next steps luckily we
are in a position where we can access
the data and the bamboo team has kindly
accepted to share it a plan is in the
next two months we'll do exploratory
analysis to find the key signals that
really matter in terms of the outcomes
we have and then as a part of that same
process we in the next four to six
months we would want to deploy a
classifier that can just look at these
sensors and help nurses make prioritized
decisions and beyond that I think our
whole is that it actually gets
integrated into what bamboo is doing and
we do trials with this technology that's
it
thank you
the whole time or is it you know at this
point in time this baby does not look
healthy or healthy so it's sort of much
more yes it is the time period by time
period classification in fact I think
what we actually do is to look at only
the change in each baby right so at any
point of time let's say at time T we
look at the baby's signals and video at
time t minus 1 and we try to see how
much this change corresponds to a
healthy versus a normality but really I
think we want to do it at within at the
same time so that nurses can respond
yeah
very good question well the next group
said so
yes yeah I think that's a good point
yeah so we as I said we have to strike
some right balance but I think the other
side is way more worse so we took the
conservative side but hopefully I think
our algorithms will be able to detect
with some accuracy that this